- First of all, I have to thank, Priya,
for inviting me to this conference
and of course also, Ty,
for the collaboration.
And I enjoyed this two
days, I learned a lot.
And you know that I particularly like
interdisciplinary situations,
so it is good for me.
And as you can see, the
title of my presentation is,
Abduction, Models, and Creativity.
There is also subtitle, I
will deal with the subtitle
in the end of the presentation
in which there is the concept
of eco-cognitive openness.
We will see what is
eco-cognitive openness.
But referred to human
scientific inferences
because I can anticipate that I think
in current artificial
intelligence program,
for instance, deep learning,
there is not a situation
of eco-cognitive openness.
Okay, so where is the tool?
Okay, so first of all, I want
to propose to your attention
a concept of inference
that is very general,
that you can adopt, you
cannot adopt, as you prefer.
Anyway, it is a concept of inference
that is due to a great
American philosophers.
Philosopher that is
Charles Sanders Peirce.
Charles Sanders Peirce stated
that all thinking is in signs,
and sign can be icons,
indices, or symbols.
Moreover, it's always Peirce,
all inference is a form of sign activity
where the word sign
includes feeling, image.
Conception is archaic word
for concept and other representation.
So as you can see Peirce and
I strongly agree with him
and also recent cognitive
science agrees implicitly
with Peirce says that for instance,
an emotion is a cognitive
activity is an inference,
is a way of reacting to a situation.
And so also images during these two days,
there were a lot of presentation
in which models, images, diagrams,
artifacts were described.
And so these of course are
inferences in when they are able
to lead from one point to another point.
We have an inference
following this concept.
And in Kantian words, all
synthetic forms of cognition,
synthetic form of cognition.
In Kantian word means
for instance propositions
that deal with the word,
okay, Kantian divided
between synthetic a priority cognition
for instance mathematics and synthetic,
a posterior recognition
that is a considerable part
of the thinking activity is model-based.
Of course model-based reasoning
wise, it's peculiar creative
relevance when embedded
in abductive processes.
So Peirce the great American philosopher.
We are in United States, so
it is good to have Peirce.
Abduction, what is abduction?
You know what is deduction?
Also because yesterday we have
a rich apology of deduction
given by Jill Scher.
And do you remember deduction
starts from true premises and you are sure
that you arrive to true consequences.
This is not the case of abduction
because an example of
abduction is in logistic terms
in first predicate logic
is all men are mortal.
Socrates is mortal.
Conclusion, Socrates is a man.
This is called fallacy of
affirming the consequence
because of course it is
very simple and intuitive.
Socrates can be a dog, okay?
But you can perform of course abduction.
That is, we can classify abduction
as reasoning to hypothesis, okay?
Every kind of hypothesis.
The classical example is
making a diagnostic hypothesis.
And another better example
is discovering something new.
Peirce gave the example of Kepler
that discovers the elliptic
orbit of the planet.
So what is important to note
that abduction is an inference.
Deduction is an inference.
Induction is an inference.
Usually we consider induction
as a kind of generalization.
Abduction is so to say
more extended, okay?
If you are using an analogy,
it is more difficult to
classify analog reasoning
as a kind of induction
even if John Stewart Mill
said that it was possible
because he had an extended
view of induction.
But it is a kind of abduction
because do you remember that
yesterday we had David Kaiser
that said we deal with
the cosmological area,
and so they have to look at the past.
There was also a recent presentation
regarding the past abduction
is good for looking at the past
because in archeology
that is not cosmology,
you have the same problem.
And he said, he said
that they use a toy model
and theological reasoning
to make hypothesis, okay?
They are making abduction.
During the breakfast, you also remember
that you also use computational models,
but there were also other presentation
that regarded the computational models.
So model-based abduction means that week
you can perform abductions using models,
diagrams, visualization, artifacts.
You can use take advantage
of an external artifact
to try to arrive to hypothesis.
But you can of course
also reach a hypothesis
using sentential abduction
that refers to the use
for instance, on natural language
or of a technical language.
We can consider sentential
abduction for instance
an abduction that breach using logic.
There are many logical abduction
that try to give deductive
models of abductive.
They of course are non-classical logic.
So, model-based means that
we are dealing with diagrams.
This elementary diagram
is extremely important
in the history of western thought
because it is a diagram, a clear diagram
that permitted Nikolai
Ivanovich Lobachevsky
to discover the non-Euclidean
hyperbolic geometry.
So it is a diagram that
to come back to this,
to the conference of these
days, cosmologist again,
but also Einstein all
adapt to this diagram
because they are able to
speak of many kind of space
and so on as we have seen yesterday.
So this is an example
because you know in
the elementary geometry
until the beginning of 19th century,
it was necessary to use diagrams.
And diagram is a model, an
external model that you have
to depict for instance in a blackboard.
So here there are some examples
of model-based cognition,
simulative reasoning of any kind.
Analogy, already quoted.
Visual iconic reasoning, special
thing, thought experiment.
The most farmers thought
experiment of the history
of western thought is
the thought experiment
of Galileo Galilei that
permitted to him to surpass
the Aristotelian vision of
the falling of the bodies.
And it was completely
internal in this case
without any reference to external aspects.
Perception is of course a
kind of model-based activity.
Peirce considered a perception
as a kind of abduction.
We perceive the word in it is
a kind of automatic abduction.
The cat perceive is the
word in another way.
So, it is a kind of synthetic cognition.
Visual imaginary, many
people use visual imagery
through reach result, but
also in deductive reasoning
there are model-based aspects.
When you make a proof, a demonstration,
for instance Beth's method
of semantic tableaux,
Girard's geometry of
proof, you are dealing
with the kind of
externalization of your proof
that it can be more or less good.
And it is in part emotion.
Emotion, I think that
you agree with me also
because in the research cognitive science
there is the tradition of the four E.
Embodied, embedded,
enacted, extended cognition
that considers the role of
the body extreme important
in cognitive activities.
So when you are in front of a situation in
and you feel an emotion, the
emotion is not propositional,
it is a kind of reaction that anyway
fear for instance explains so
to say the situation, okay?
Just, okay, this is an example
of a model used by Watson,
a creek and creek when
they considered two snakes.
This was important for the
discovery of the DNA and the air.
And just to show this example.
This is a time model of
the planetary system.
I guess that your model
are more complicated.
Oh, the same, okay, good.
They're very simple.
For instance, useful not
necessarily for a creative.
Do you remember that I
put the name, creativity?
Abduction is the correct word
to speak about creativity,
not necessarily they
are used in creativity,
but they can be used for
instance to didactic aim.
But there is also
another kind of abduction
that I call manipulative abduction.
It is a kind of thinking through doing.
What is thinking through doing?
You are in front of a situation
where you are looking for hypothesis.
The historical example is Ampere.
Ampere was not able to formulate
any kind of hypothesis,
but he was able to build
complicated artifacts
full of niggles.
And thank you to the
manipulation of these artifacts,
he was able to reach the hypothesis.
So thinking through doing is different
from planning and manipulation
that is more similar
to the experiment to
planning and experiment.
But it is important in
scientific creativity.
I deal in my presentation
with scientific creativity.
Construal is the name
given by David Gooding,
an epistemologist, an epistemologist
to this kind of artifacts that
people and scientists build.
For instance also sketches,
not necessarily external
artifact to try to go ahead,
and it is important in my opinion.
I also seen that that
in the Frank program,
Priya spoke about learning-
- [Priya] By doing.
- By doing.
It is similar.
In this case, it is related
to the problem of creativity.
Okay, again, the diagram,
this diagram is the birth,
represents so to say the
birth of modern mathematics,
so the abandonment on
the part of mathematics
of the intuitive word.
This was not good for philosophy
because philosophy was the only discipline
that dealt with non-intuitive
aspect, but also mathematics.
And soon also science would've reached
this kingdom of non-intuitive.
Okay, I told you that
abduction is a fallacy
because I made the example,
this logistic example.
So yesterday we had an apology,
a rich apology of deduction.
In a certain sense I will deal
an apology of fallacious reasoning
because abduction as would content
is a mistaking reasoning.
A mistake which of course
with some frequency in real argument
and which is characteristically deceptive.
Hasty generalization and verecundiam
are considered inductively
with weak inference.
So do not pay attention to all this work,
pay attention to the fact
that fallacies of score are fallacies.
So they are not sure
as a kind of inference,
but sometimes they are
good because for instance,
hasty generalization in
children and also in mobs
is able to save their lives
because they make a
generalization only for instance
with one example, one negative example.
So in this sense, a fallacious reasoning
presents a kind of eco-cognitive
use fullness sometimes.
In logic it is also called
when you make a fallacy
and you arrive to a truth,
it is also called material validity
because you do not have the
correct form of the reason,
but you arrive to the truth, okay?
So, okay, as you can see there is written
the so-called fallacy are fruitful.
This is a fallacy.
These are simple stupid images, okay?
Consider that I like slides,
colored is not academically correct,
but anyway I am a old researcher,
so you can permit to use colored light.
Go.
Okay.
This is a book,
a, "Springer Handbook of
Modern-Based Science."
It is more than 1,000 pages
and there are the illustration
of many kinds of modeling.
As you can see, models are classified
as make-believe, parables.
Lexican Tribes said they are parables.
Functional, explanatory, systemic action
as artifacts revealing capacities.
Traditionally epistemologist say abstract
are ideal and/or abstract.
So some epistemologist
said, but they are fictional
because they're abstract, they are ideal.
Fictional as (speaks foreign language)
I do not agree with this visual
because I do not think that in science,
models are fictional.
Models of course are different
from the possible final
result in terms of knowledge,
but they are the only tool
that was heuristically capable
to arrive to the end.
So in this sense they
are extremely fruitful
and it is not important if they are false
from some perspective
to abstract to ideal.
But it is important that they
permits to the researcher
to go ahead fruitfully in his research.
Let's go ahead.
Models consider that
models are distributed
and never abstract.
This is a sub philosophical consideration,
but it is obvious a reality
of course in epical sense
models for instance, the model of pendulum
is ideal and abstract.
But anyway, every kind of
model is a concrete materiality
because it is a drawing a sheet of paper,
it is something in a blackboard,
it is a computational
representation of a situation.
And in this case it is a
physical representation
inside a digital computer for instance.
So, it is something material.
So in this sense, but only in this sense
they are never abstract.
Manifest model is a
model that is acquired.
Imagine a collective
of scientists in a lab.
They are building a computational
model for instance of,
there is an example, an
approximation of neurons,
one physical in vitro
networks of cultural neurons
and the other consisting in
a computational counterpart
if the computational
counterpart is adopted
by that collective of scientists.
So in that case it is a manifest model
that can work for not necessary forever,
but can be also eliminated.
You can withdraw a model
and produce another one.
But if it is manifested, it
is because it is adopted.
Model are so to say just models
that idolize and/or abstract.
But these last two aspects
have to be strictly criticized
in the light of recent
epistemological cognitive literature
as related to the special
kinds of epistemic actions,
abstractness and ideality
cannot be solely related
to empirical in inadequacy
and or to theoretical view
of the scientific enterprise.
I dealt with the problem
of fictionality of model
that is typical of the
community of the epistemologist
in the last online
conference of two years ago
on inference here organized by Priya,
so I do not spend a lot
of time to speak again
against fictionalism in epistemology.
Oh this is a model historically important
because it was the model built by Maxwell
and it was important to permit to Maxwell
to go ahead to reach important
result concerning magnetism.
Of course to finish the
problem of fictionally.
If you see the scientific
enterprise in a static way,
so you have the result,
the final knowledge reached
and you have the model
that was used to arrive
to that result.
Of course models seems fictional
sometimes without coherence
inconsistent and so,
but it is because you do not adopt
a dynamic view of certificate enterprise.
Okay, creativity.
I hope that I was able to
explain what is abduction,
what is a model.
In our two days there were
many example of models.
Ah, okay.
There was also the presentation
by, what was the name?
Paso, that spoke, Paso, okay,
sorry, we look Paso that said,
but not deductive inferences
are present in mathematics.
For instance, in reverse mathematics
there is the problem
of having some theorems
and archeologically so to say
you have to find the actions
that are able to lead to the
so non-deductible reasoning
is why the spread.
It is a fallacy, but it is good
because it is related to creativity
because one of the
characters of creativity
is that you have to deal
with creative abduction
that are not the so-called
selective abduction,
the ones for is of the diagnosis.
And so creativity is important, okay?
I told you that you have to see science,
this is a kind of suggestion
as you considering this audience,
an audience of philosopher
of science, consider,
always consider science from
a dynamic point of view.
That was also a suggestion given by Popper
and all the epistemologies after Popper.
Okay, so what is eco-epistemic warfare?
So the models are fiction
or epistemic weapons.
I think that they are epistemic weapons.
You can use fictions in other aspects
of scientific enterprise.
For instance, if you have to get funds,
you can also invent. (chuckles)
I am not suggested to
invent a thought experiment.
But Galileo invented a
lot of thought experiment
to try to sustain his theory in the book
or by Paul Feyerabend against,
he thought there is an illustration
of these smart activities
of Galileo that is epistemic warfare.
But when you are inside
your activity of research,
you cannot use fictions in the sense
of stupidities or extremely false
invented thought experiment or experiment.
But you have to use models
that work in a good way.
When you arrive to a
hypothesis abductivity,
Charles Sanders Peirce
said, usually you arrive
to something acceptable, okay?
But not necessarily is the
result that you are looking for.
So in for instance in a diagnosis,
you have to adopt some criteria.
For instance, the more
simple of hypothesis
that you can guess is
the better hypothesis
has to be consistent with your knowledge.
But this, for example, is not
true in the case of creative.
Because you can create a hypothesis
that is completely against the status
of knowledge of that period.
It is unrelevant, it is
completely unacceptable
and in many cases also unaccepted
then can be accepted later on
because the situation of the
background knowledge changes.
The Occam's razor is one of the criteria
for choosing hypothesis.
The simple one maybe is the best.
If you are in a television
series, "CSI" Miami,"
maybe the simple hypothesis
about the murderer
is the simple one.
The wife of course, or the
husband or the, yeah...
In medical diagnosis there
is something similar.
And an example of fictional character
that doesn't have to be used
in the case of scientific models, okay?
That person is Paul Feyerabend.
The one that analyzed all
the rhetorical activities
of Galileo Galilei to
defend the new physics,
to defend the birth of
mother science, okay?
So epistemic warfare, I already
explained to you what is.
It is the use of both
fictions but also of models.
Because if you are looking
for the scientific truths,
even if we all know that
scientific truths are all withdraw
all because this is
typical of truth science,
we can call that a epistemic warfare.
Okay, the last consideration
that I want to submit to your attention
is the fact that during
my studies on abduction,
I also, it was published
recently published a handbook
of abductive cognition of
2,000 pages that I edited,
and so it is full of example
of abduction everywhere and so on.
I reached the conviction
that when you have to make an abduction,
both in the case of selective abduction,
that is the one that is
typical of diagnosis,
but also in the case of
the creative abduction,
it is important the
so-called situatedness.
And to make good abduction,
you need an optimization of, what I call,
eco-cognitive situatedness.
This means that you have,
there was a presentation
regarding the constraints
just a few hours ago.
So you do not have to have for instance,
to many constraints or
the wrong constraints
because you can be, to
make an example Einstein,
but in front of a bad
eco-cognitive situatedness,
you are not able to discover anything.
So thanks to an eco-cognitive model,
eco-cognitive means that refers also
to the exploitation of the environment.
Cognitive science speaks
of distributed cognition.
Human beings always
starting from the minutes
used to distribute
cognition in external tools
to delegate cognitive aspect
to the external materialities.
And eco-cognitive model means
that I refer to this aspect,
so optimization of eco-cognitive openness
and situatedness you have to optimize.
And there are of course many
ways in diagnostic reasoning,
there will be a kind of
optimization that is good.
This is a practical, this is
not a philosophical problem.
It is a practical
problem and in archeology
you will be in another
situation and so on.
But third, I am almost at
the end of my presentation,
I contend that in the case of science,
you need the maximization
of echo cognitive
environmental situatedness
and that recognition.
For example in AlphaZero, that
is a deep learning program,
you are not dealing with the situation.
Also in the case of deep learning tool
or deep artificial intelligence
that deal with big data,
research says that humans always have
to make a curation of the data.
And this is a human performance
to avoid the spurious
generalization that can generate it.
So to conclude, say if you are,
if this is the book in which
I describe these things,
if you need to maximize
cognition, for instance,
to make a good new discovery,
we need new discoveries in science.
We have to take care of
eco-cognitive openness.
So the question is, is
discoverability jeopardized?
it's almost the last sentence.
Currently various aspect
of decision making,
the commercialized certificate research
already quoted in these days.
For instance in biomedical areas
are jeopardizing discoverability
science, social creativity,
and human creative abduction in general.
So they are jeopardizing
human creativity, why?
Because the excess of
rendering sacred knowledge,
because of patenting,
because of business aims.
Of course it is exactly the country
of the tradition of modern
science in which always
there was a knowledge
motion in the transparency.
So I guess, but I'm not
alone in this situation
to that the eco-cognitive openness
is as some says jeopardized.
And this is not good
because at the same time
also human creativity can be jeopardized.
I think that we do not
have any other slides.
"The Handbook of Abductive Cognition."
And the last book was with
the title, "Discoverability:
The Urgent Need of an
Ecology of Human Creativity."
I had the opportunity to
read some parts of the,
and see click of the current
Pope Francis about ecology.
He's a huge (speaks in
Latin) is the name in Latino,
about all kinds of ecology.
And so creative was not so much quoted,
but I quote human creativity.
Human creativity needs to be treated
from a ecological point of view.
So this is a conclusion
that is that intertwining
between epistemology, social
epistemology and ethics
because there are all
these aspects all together.
Thank you very much for your input.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, Lorenzo,
for putting together a
lot of features about,
this is a conversation that
some of us have been having.
What constitutes a discovery
and what are the characteristics of a,
this scientific discovery or
any discovery for that matter.
And so I think this is a
very interesting framework
that brings in creativity, originality
into the frame of models
and scientific activity.
Thank you, yeah.
Questions?
- No questions.
- No, no.
- I'm questionable.
- So since it's my favorite way
of thinking about sciences
through abduction,
because again, in my
experience and what I've seen,
anything that is worth of
someone's sleepless nights
has been done by abduction,
not by sitting in front of
and writing some equations
outside mathematics,
I'm a biologist.
But what I think it's a good opportunity
to bring another view on
how we get inferences,
a view that became more acceptable
due to advances in medicine,
which was able to bring people
from commerce and so on.
And it's a hundred years
old in western tradition
that's coming from Frederick
Myers and William James.
The idea is that there is a,
what they call subliminal
part of the world
that basically we have a
visible part of the world,
there's a subliminal part of the world,
and geniuses is an extreme case of people
who have extreme ability
for this abduction
are people who can channel
something from there,
and some people can't at all
and there's a degree of...
But basically it's a view
that as something to consider
in addition to a view
that everything is done by
computational machine in our head
and that the knowledge can
come to some other way.
Let's put it this way.
- Okay, thank you.
So I can add that when you
use for instance equations,
these already happen with Galileo.
You have to have at your
disposal the concept of function.
Without the concept of function,
you are compelled to make the physics,
there is totalitarian physics
that is only qualitative.
In the case of Newton, you
have to have at your disposal
the differential calculus
and as Paso thought,
you have to discover the
differential calculus.
And this was made by Leibniz and Newton.
So this was the fluid of
abduction in mathematics.
There is a famous book by Lakatos,
"Proof: Demonstration and Refutation,"
that is about this constructure.
And so of course you can take
advantage to make abduction,
for instance, in medical
reasoning of external tool,
computational tools and so on.
There are many books already
written about the role
of artificial intelligence
in scientific discovery
as a kind of help of
tool of an external aid
to your heuristics.
- [Priya] Next question.
- [Audience Member] Thanks.
I really enjoyed your talk.
I couldn't help but notice
that you avoided the words,
inspiration and intuition.
- The word?
- [Audience Member] You avoided the words,
inspiration and intuition,
and I was wondering why you did not.
- It is good question.
But I solved this question
using Charles Sanders Peirce, okay?
Charles Sanders Peirce, me
too, say in human beings
there is the possibility of the
so-called instinctual abduction.
That is when you produce instantly
and suddenly an hypothetical result.
And it is true, it is good, okay?
There is, in this case,
it is difficult to analyze
because you do not have any awareness
of the mechanism until now.
Maybe in the future there will
be some neurological research
that will be able to explain.
- [Priya] On the mouse brain
and the mouse retina, right?
- Like they figure out the
mouse brain for instance.
But it is typical of human
beings to use instinct.
So for instance, some physicians
are particularly endowed
with this capacity to make
instantly a diagnostic.
This is typical of human being.
You cannot implement in a,
I collaborated with the
computational scientist
to programs at the first decade
of artificial intelligence
on diagnostic medical reasoning.
And in that case you
have to write a program,
and so then you can say the result
of the machine is instinctual
but it is fake because in
reality you know which program
was able to arrive to the result.
This is typical.
It is a kind of philosophical
and psychological term,
and so I avoid the data just because
there was not opportunity
to quote extinct abduction.
Also in animals, in animal cognition,
there is this capacity
of making abduction,
for instance in superior
mammals and cats and so on.
And of course they are not
using our syntactical language,
but they are capable to arrive to result.
- [Priya] Thanks, Lorenzo.
Eduardo, very quick question
because we wanna break for tea
unless you want to carry it over.
Okay, great.
Thank you very much.
So, let's break for tea and
come back for the final talk
and discussion at the end of the workshop.
Thanks, everyone.
Let's thank Lorenzo again.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for your attention.
(bright music)